my name is julia belk i'm a duke energy
research and innovation scholar and my
project is about providing electricity
to people who aren't sufficiently don't
don't get power from their national
power infrastructure and right now today
that number is about two billion people
um so what we're building is a micro
grid which is an electrical network to
uh connect
electrically connect communities so some
people get solar panels uh to put power
into the grid and other people can take
power out of the grid um and then they
trade the power between themselves using
mobile payments
so
this we connected five people last
summer in june um that was one
generator one solar panel and four
people using that electricity but right
now what is lacking is the technology to
be able to connect multiple solar panels
all to the same network